Katherine Webb macaron flaunts her  envious post-baby bye  you probably wouldn't have guessed  Katherine gave birth just one month ago  in this new bikini clad selfie she  captioned the ab flaunting photo from  the fitting room shopping for bikini  season  shameless selfie but seeing progress  just from breastfeeding pretty awesome  how the body works and preparing herself  from the inevitable haters of the  Internet she wrote note I gained 44  pounds during my pregnancy so this post  isn't meant to be humble say what you  want but I feel great about myself even  with the extra cellulite on my butt and  stretch marks so shoot me if I felt  banging for once in this bikini okay  Katherine and her husband Cincinnati  Bengals quarterback AJ McCarron welcomed  their baby boy on May 24th